Vladimir Putin and angular Merkel held a
joint conference in Moscow just hours
before a ceasefire in Libya planned for
Saturday at midnight Turkey and Russia
and the UN representative for Libya have
called for the ceasefire but the
Warlord's relief after has refused to
adhere to it we welcomed the German
initiative to have a conference in
Berlin on Libya and we would like to
invite all involved parties and states
all decisions should be coordinated with
those involved in the Libya conflict and
we should also have mr. selami as a UN
representative let's remain so process
she's joining us from Moscow to talk us
through what they take away message was
from that press conference them well it
was clear that the main visits were for
Angela Merkel to come to Moscow was to
get everyone on board for this peace
conference in Berlin and one of the
reasons that this peace conference can
actually happen is that it needs to be a
ceasefire in Libya and that's what she
discussed with President Putin Putin and
her one earlier last week called for
this ceasefire to happen at midnight in
a little less than four hours from now
and a Putin was still optimistic he said
in the press conference that their speed
odysseus fire will actually happen he
didn't only talk to merkel today he was
actually quite busy diplomatically he
called also the crown prince for the
united arab emirates earlier in the
morning also someone who's actually on
the side of countries on the side of
Khalifa Haftar and he also had a
conversation on the phone with the Emir
of Qatar
so although after has said that he
rejects and he calls for a ceasefire
there might be some plan here that has
been cooked up by President Putin and
we'll have to see in a little less than
four hours if this is actually going to
materialize interestingly also that
during this press conference it was a
bit of an awkward moment when the
President Putin was asked about the
allegations by Turkey that Russian
mercenaries are fighting on the side of
Khalifa Haftar
200 to thousands of them and Putin said
that
well there might be a Russian citizens
but there's nothing a state-sponsored
here and they're also not being paid by
the state but this is allegedly the
Wagner the so-called Wagner group who
sends these mercenaries and this is a
close confident of President Putin
Angela Merkel of course is anxiously
waiting for this feast ceasefire to
materialize because she doesn't want any
more bloodshed and she's also worried
about more refugees coming to Europe as
specifically to Germany okay it's that
fasten thank you Oh Mohamed Abdullah had
this in Tripoli and says it has yet to
be seen if Putin can convince Hefner and
his forces to implement the ceasefire on
the grounds ceasefire does not seem to
be accepted by the both right warring
factions yes as you know that after has
rejected this ceasefire call by both
Ardoin and Putin and meanwhile fighting
renewed today in southern Tripoli and
government military sources say that
they have killed Sudanese mercenaries
fighting along with half those forces in
a couple of axes in southern Tripoli but
the question now is whether or not this
ceasefire coal would be translated into
action on the ground as you know that
many people here especially in the west
of Libya are calling for calm actually
the government of national Accord have
accepted the ceasefire agreement but
again it's not being implemented on the
ground but the question now is that many
people are asking here in the west of
Libya whether or not prison Putin can
put pressure on half those forces to
stop the military escalation in southern
Tripoli as the question he answered
about the Vagner Russian mercenaries
fighting along would have to respond he
said that did you not belong to the
state and they don't get paid by the
state but again the Russians and they're
making a change on the ground and they
have been helping have those forces
taken control of several locations they
have been escalating the fighting in
southern Tripoli inocent Gomati is in
affairs analyst on Libya at the Sadiq
Institute
he says the peace conference to be held
in Berlin is an effort to unite the
international community
well the conference is actually almost a
misnomer so when we look at the actual
content and the participants of the
conference it's a conference that tried
to get international players to agree
among themselves about who they're gonna
support in Libya it's not a conference
between both parties
but in Khalifa Haftar and the GA failure
Siraj that's not the that's not the
subject of the conference the subject is
even more startling when we think there
is so much this unity in the
international community but they have to
have a conference about finding a
unified position amongst themselves
before they can even bring Livingstone
table that's the main issue here is that
there is so much that is being said
about how the international community
supports the GNA and typically that's
the the UN backed government wherein in
truth they offer almost middle to no
support which has been the case for the
last nine months which is one penny per
half that has not been sanctioned why
has not been condemned as what has not
been criticized and that's why the UN
backed government the Tiffany have to go
to Turkey for acquiring military support
over the last month and a half that's
really what we saw for foiling that it's
the it's the international community's
position number one but has being called
into question and that's what the
subject what this Berlin conference is I
think my very very far away from what
these will settlement questioning and I
think that's because there seems to be
almost no appetite to rein in on the
backers of half dome and there's really
important things that could be done an
arms embargo we're probably the first
now that's gonna ripen the local
factions to believe that they can't
continue this way